do people really change I mean real  lasting positive change I sure hope so  because that's what we do and then we  sing about it you wait for the day you  prep for a year and win the big day is  finally here you take a jerk and work to  turn them around why are they singing oh  because this is a musical what is all of  this the afterlife  [Music]  I made a feeling oh come on really  you show them their life and you hope  for the switch and when it goes off  without a hitch this Christmas train is  [Music]  [Music]  it's very necessary  [Music]  [Music]  dude I can't dance like this are you  gonna be able to keep up with all this I  mean if I start dancing I'm gonna shut  it down man everybody gonna look bad  Jingle Bells  but it's a natural high  [Music]  ER  Christmas  [Music]  hey does somebody clear out our search  history after we die  [Music]  la la la  la